MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
all for stopping by today,
and we have an exciting
talk at Google.
We have Phil Terry, the founder
and CEO of Collaborative Gain.
He runs the Councils, which
is a collaborative network
of senior digital leaders.
Phil has written
about collaboration
and the power of asking for
help in the "Harvard Business
Review" and recently published
the book "Customers Included,"
which he is here to
talk to us about.
The book details
his 15 years as CEO
of Creative Good, a
pioneering customer experience
consultancy, and so he's helped
hundreds of senior leaders
help each other run better,
more innovative, more
customer-inclusive companies.
And so he also sits
on the board of Mind
The Product, which is a global
community of digital product
leaders, startups
like StellaService
and universities like the
Harvard Business School's Rock
Center for Entrepreneurship and
the USC Institute of Innovation
and Startup Garage.
So with that, please join me
in welcoming Phil to Google.
Thank you.
PHIL TERRY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Whoo.
It's great to be here.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you, everyone
on Google Hangouts
and watching later on YouTube.
I was thinking today,
when I got here,
I haven't been here
actually since 2002.
It's a little bit changed.
[CHUCKLES]
Marissa Mayer brought me in.
In the early days, she
was a founding member
of these Councils
that we run here
at Collaborative Gain, which--
as Bradley Horowitz, who's
our host today-- said it
brings together executives
from around the world who care
about the customer experience
and who want to really
ask each other for help.
I'm a big fan of
asking for help.
So we're going to talk about
my book "Customers Included."
I want to walk through some
of the stories from the book.
I think the most
important question
that we ask in
the book is really
a simple one and
somewhat obvious,
which is we are not
the first people
to say the customer
is important.
Right?
I really think we can
all agree this is not
a revolutionary new insight.
Wow.
In fact, I trace the history
of customer experience
and the recognition
that customers
need to be the focus of
businesses back to 1954
when Peter Drucker wrote
his first book "Practice
of Management," and
so it's a long time.
And many other people, including
some of the key leaders,
of course, here at
Google and many of you
here in the audience, believe
the customer is important.
So we all can agree on that.
But I think we can also agree
that we need to sort of look
closely at-- if we
agree, that everyone
knows this is important,
more or less-- why is it
that most companies
don't actually do it?
Right?
So as customers
and as executives,
we know that in most cases,
most products and services
are, frankly, not that good.
Right?
They go from bad
to OK, and there's
only a few incredibly delightful
things that are out there.
So why don't more
companies do it?
And one of the-- the talk will
really try to address that,
but one of things I
want you to keep in mind
is that knowing it's important
is clearly not enough.
We have to think about habits,
we have to think about actions,
and we have to
think about-- what
are some of the
barriers and obstacles?
Now, I've been on
this book tour.
I've done about 90
talks in the last year.
I'll be at Apple tomorrow.
I'm sort of doing the Silicon
Valley swing this week,
which is a lot of
fun, and it's really
been great to be out
at so many companies
talking about these stories.
But it's also been great to
be interacting with people
along the way, including flight
attendants and taxi drivers.
And in the last
couple of weeks, I've
had some conversations that have
had a big impact on me that I
want to actually share
with you before we
jump into some of the stories.
OK.
This is one of my taxi
drivers in Boston.
OK.
So I was there a
couple of weeks ago,
and it was during the big storm.
Right?
It was 25 inches of snow.
There was travel banned.
Then the next day,
I got in a cab.
And I asked this gentlemen
how long he'd been driving,
and he said, "Oh, about a year."
I said, "Oh, that's great.
What'd you do before?"
He said, "Well, I owned
several car dealerships."
I said, "Really?
Wow.
How did you go from car
dealerships to taxi driver?
I mean, those are usually
profitable businesses,"
and he said, "Well,
I had a"-- and then
he told me a personal story.
And he had a heart
attack, and he
was in a coma for three months.
I'm like, "Oh, wow.
OK."
So that sort of-- I had to
think about that for minute,
and we talked a little bit about
what that experience was like.
You can imagine.
And then I said,
"Why does that mean
you lost your
businesses, though?
I'm sure your employees
and even customers
probably rallied around
you," and he said, "Well,
actually, no.
I had been a greedy
and arrogant owner.
I had mistreated
my employees, and I
had mistreated my customers."
"And when I got
sick, they all fled.
And by the time I got
out of the hospital,
my car dealerships
were bankrupt."
I'm like, "Oh, wow.
Really?"
And this is what--
when he picked me up,
he was one of most
gracious, humble people
I had met as a taxi driver.
Right?
And then he went on
to say how grateful he
is for having had
this experience.
I said, "Really?
Wow."
He said, "Well, I'm
closer to my family.
My wife, thank God, didn't
leave me during all those years
that I was kind of a jerk,
and she hung in there with me
when I was sick.
I'm closer to my children
and now my grandchildren,
and I'm filled with gratitude."
And I mean, I-- so I posted this
up on some social media sites,
and the response was
enormous, as you can imagine.
And I just feel
so touched by him.
I feel like I'm here
representing his story.
And among other things,
we have to remember
that customers are real people.
Employees are real people.
When we kind of move away from
the frameworks and the guiding
philosophy and
the principles, it
comes down to real
live human beings.
Right?
Like us.
And it's so important
for us to remember that
and to remember that, when
we treat our customers well
and we treat our
employees well, they'll
give us the benefit
of the doubt.
They'll hang in there with
us when times are tough,
when the economy is bad, or
when we're in the hospital,
like this guy.
But if we take
advantage of them,
if we don't really listen to
and have empathy for them,
well, we won't have
that margin of safety,
will we, when times get tough?
All right.
So I just wanted to
share that with you.
It's really had an impact on me.
These two housekeepers.
During the Boston storm
and the travel ban was on,
no one could leave their homes.
I was stuck in my
hotel room, and I
figured they're not
going to clean the room.
I can handle that.
Right?
And at 1 o' clock, these
two women knock on my door.
I said, "What are you doing?"
They said, "We're here
to clean your room."
I said, "But how
did you get here?"
They said, "We walked 30
minutes through the blizzard
to get here."
Now, there's two
things about that.
One is I thanked them, and
I said, "That's incredible."
And I gave them each a very
nice tip, and I said, "Wow.
Thank you.
Thank you."
And then of course, I thought
I'm not happy, actually,
with the hotel.
The hotel should have
paid them to stay home,
not to risk life and limb
to come and clean our rooms.
We're customers.
We care about how companies
treat their employees
as much as we also care
about our own experience.
But I think about
them and I sort of
think I'm representing
them here today.
Right?
And I bet they're Google
users, by the way.
Right?
OK.
All right.
So let's shift gears and move
into some of the stories.
And then a couple
weeks ago, I was
at the pre-IPO roadshow
for Shake Shack.
Anybody here Shake Shack fans?
Yeah.
Awesome.
That's Randy Garutti,
the CEO of Shake Shack.
And when the analysts
at this kind of-- it
was in Wall Street in New York.
Right?
So these are hard, bitten,
cynical, skeptical analysts.
Right?
Talking about the
numbers and, well,
what about In-N-Out Burger
and blah, blah, blah.
And Randy says,
"You know, you might
think we're in the
hamburger business."
And we are, of course.
We make hamburgers, and we
make great custards and shakes.
Right?
Some of you have had those.
But he said, "Actually,
the business we're in
is supporting the development of
the leadership of our employees
and creating an experience
for our customers.
Yes.
Certainly, we make
good hamburgers,
but it's bigger than that."
And they went on to
talk in a non-cynical
and really loving, genuine,
authentic, empathetic way
about their team and
about their customers.
And I was watching
this analyst group
in Wall Street who were what?
Huh?
What are you talking about?
[MUMBLING] This is not right.
You know, it was like
it did not compute.
Right?
But they understand that it's
not just about the burgers.
It's about the
overall experience
and the way they
treat each other
and the way they treat their
customers at a human level.
Right?
Real, living,
breathing human people.
OK.
So if you hand me a copy
of the book-- thank you.
So the book came out
in October of 2013,
so just about a year ago,
a little over a year ago.
And we walk through
a number of stories.
First, of course,
reminding readers
that, despite the
fact that everyone
knows we should
include the customer,
it actually doesn't
happen very often.
And then trying to
answer the question why?
Right?
So let's just do a
couple reminders.
So the first case
study in the book
is about a government
project that
was politically contentious.
And when it launched, it failed.
So here it is.
The 2006 Border Patrol Project.
OK.
So Congress, in its infinite
wisdom, first of all,
took 10 years to build
a 2,000-mile fence along
the border of Mexico.
Do we have any
engineers here today?
Yes?
Right.
OK.
So if I told you, let's
build a 2,000-mile,
your engineering mentality
would tell me what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL TERRY: [CHUCKLES] What?
[LAUGHTER]
If you can build it,
how do you maintain it?
So then they said, OK.
This isn't working.
And then Boeing raised their
hand, and said, oh, hire us.
Hire us.
We'll build an electronic fence.
You know, we'll use
that technology stuff.
You know, that cool internet
stuff and, you know,
digital stuff, and
it'll be great.
And so they built it,
and of course, it failed.
All right.
They fired the administrator
from the Homeland Security
Department who was in
charge of the project.
And they brought a new one on,
and the poor guy's first job
was to go out on PBS and
explain what had just happened.
OK.
So the interviewer on PBS
says, oh, wait a minute.
You mean to tell me that
you built this whole thing
for the Border Patrol?
So Kroft says, you built a
multi-billion dollar project
for the Border Patrol,
and-- wait a minute.
You didn't ask the
Border-- you never
spent any time with
the Border Patrol
to figure out what they
might need or want?
That seems like a mistake,
and he's like, oh, yeah.
That was a huge mistake.
So literally, many, many
companies and organizations
literally don't spend a
moment with their customer.
Even today, even though
we all know we should.
Right?
Dramatically unbelievable.
Border Patrol.
Let's move to Africa.
So there was an innovator
who wanted to do something
about the water access
crisis in sub-Saharan Africa.
Right?
This is an important issue.
So in many parts of rural
and semi-rural sub-Saharan
Africa, women and
girls-- and it's
almost always women and girls--
will walk a mile or two a day
to fetch water for cooking,
cleaning, and drinking.
Right?
So I think we can
all agree this is
problematic on a
number of dimensions.
Right?
So this innovator said
let's do something about it.
Let's build a play pump.
OK?
So we'll create a
merry-go-round--
this is a good idea,
it sounds like anyway.
Merry-go-round that
the kids will play on.
Right?
And this is helpful
because we don't
have electricity in
many of these areas.
So we'll use the action of
the merry-go-round essentially
to be a pump that'll
pump water from further
away and up into
this water tower.
OK?
Around the water
tower, we'll put ads.
All right.
The ads will help us
pay for this system.
And then we'll just
put a spigot nearby,
and we'll use gravity to
bring the water back down.
OK.
So it sounds good.
So he goes to the
Bush administration,
and they say great.
And they write a check.
He goes to the Clinton Global
Initiative, and they say great.
We'll write a check.
All right.
So can you imagine
your next product here
at Google you get Clinton,
you get Bush, and then Jay-Z?
Jay-Z says great.
I'll through a
launching party for you
at Madison Square Garden.
Right?
Fantastic.
Then venture capitalists,
like Steve Case, pile on.
The whole thing.
Right?
So you kind of get the idea of
probably where I'm going here.
So what happened?
They went out.
They installed this in
some of these communities
in sub-Saharan Africa,
and it turns out
that it took water out
of these communities.
It didn't bring water in.
What?
And the Swiss
Resource Center did
an analysis of what happened.
What happened?
They said oh.
They literally spent no
time in these communities
to understand how
these people lived
or what might work or not.
Right?
So first of all, how
many of you grew up
playing on a merry-go-round?
Let me just get it.
Oh, almost everyone.
Right?
So that was a part
of our culture.
Right?
But it was not
part of the culture
in many of these communities.
So for example, when the donors
and their camera crews left,
the kids they stopped playing
on the merry-go-round.
They complained it
made them dizzy.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, that's the point.
Right?
You want to get dizzy, but
that wasn't their thing.
OK.
So the pumping action's gone.
Right?
Now, advertisers.
Do you think they showed up?
No.
You know a little
bit about ad sales.
Right?
[LAUGHS]
That was as hard to figure
out as the 2,000-mile fence.
Right?
OK.
So advertisers didn't show up.
When it was working, it
was five times slower
than the old Afridev
hand pump that
was designed in 1934 with a
lot of community consultation.
Right?
And worst of all,
when they installed,
they installed it over
the only existing borehole
that these villages had.
So when it broke down, they
literally had no water.
OK?
Oh, my gosh.
Right?
Now, interestingly, what did
Steve Case say about this?
Did he say wow.
We forgot to include
the customer.
We all know what
the issue is here.
No.
He said something
quite different,
and it's worth reflecting
on this for a moment.
He said the following thing.
You said, you know, "It's just
the very nature of innovation."
You try something.
Some things work.
Some things don't.
You throw, it up
against the wall.
Right?
Now, I'm here to
tell you-- and I
think you believe this
already-- it's not
the very nature of innovation.
This is one way to do it.
And let's just be clear
for a moment about the math
that venture capitalists use.
Right?
And it's a different
math than we
should be using in
our own companies
and when we're designing things
like play pumps for water
access in sub-Saharan Africa.
So when you're a venture
capitalist, the way it works
is you make a bunch
of investments
and you only need one
of them to go well.
Right?
And that typically
makes enough money
for you and your
limited partners.
So it turns out, if you make
10 investments as a venture
capitalist and you want
one of them to work,
you only need each investment
to have about a 40% chance
or probability of success
before your investment.
So you basically say, oh, look.
That's got a 40%
chance of success.
OK.
I'll invest there.
40%?
There, there.
You do that 10 times, you're
almost guaranteed one of them
will work.
You don't know which, but
one of them will work.
Now, can you imagine here going
to your boss and saying, OK.
Let's spend several million
dollars for this new marketing
initiative or this new
product here at Google,
and it's got a 40%
chance of success?
No.
We need to use a
different kind of math.
Right?
And there's never 100%
chance of success in anything
that we do, of course,
including not doing anything.
There's always a risk with that.
But these unforced
errors where we're simply
leaving the customer out
of the equation completely,
let's do away with those.
OK?
Can we agree?
OK.
Now, let's switch to the US
and talk about an internet case
study.
So there's a company
that, when it started,
it revolutionized a whole
category of the customer
experience.
And they had a heartfelt,
emotional connection
with their customers.
They were passionate about
what they were doing,
and their customers loved them.
OK.
And then a few years
later, they went public
and they're
investors loved them.
Right?
Wow.
The numbers are good.
Everyone's happy.
Right?
And then in 2011,
they did a couple
of things that almost
destroyed the business.
All right.
So what happened?
First, they said, oh, you
customers love us, well, great,
we love you.
We're all happy here.
We're not changing anything
or adding additional benefits
to the product, but we are
raising the price by 60%.
So thank you very much.
So yes, you can
imagine what happened.
Right?
So it's 2011.
Social media has
become mainstream.
So we were all using
it, but by 2011, so were
our parents, our
brothers and sisters.
That kind of thing.
Right?
And there's a huge backlash.
And then the CEO does a sort
of a faux apology, which
inflames passions even more.
Right?
So now, I have a little bit of
personal advice for all of us,
by the way.
In our relationships--
you know, the people
we care about, spouses,
friends, whatever--
if we've offended them,
don't do a faux topology.
And you can usually
tell by the word "if."
If you start with the word
"if," well, you're in trouble.
Right?
"If I've offended
you, I'm sorry."
Right?
How do you feel about that?
AUDIENCE: Not great.
PHIL TERRY: It doesn't work.
Does it?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So people got even angrier.
Right?
And then about a
month later, they
announced that we
know we love that.
It's a price increase
and the heartfelt apology
for how we communicated it.
Well, we have further good news.
We're splitting the
company into two,
and now you need two accounts
to do what you did before.
And then all hell broke loose.
Right?
So you probably now know
who I'm talking about.
Do you remember Jason
Alexander from Seinfeld fame?
He did the Netflix
Relief Fund at the time.
[CHUCKLES]
On the Funny or Die website.
OK.
So interestingly, what did
the tech press say about this?
Did they say, Netflix, wow.
You had that
emotional connection,
you created that
great experience,
you had that loyalty,
and you've blown it.
What are you doing?
Right?
And you remember they lost
800,000 subscribers-- close
to 5%, by the way,
of their membership.
They'd never had anything like
that before, that magnitude
problem.
And their stock price had been
in the 300s and dropped to $50.
Do you remember this?
And a friend of mine runs
a hedge fund in New York,
shorted it, rode it
all the way down.
And then interestingly,
by the way, he went long.
If I followed him in that,
I wouldn't be here today.
I'd have flown you down to
my island in the Caribbean.
[LAUGHTER]
So what did the tech press say?
Did they say, Reed
Hastings, you blew it?
No.
At least some of the tech
press said the following thing.
They said your
customers are dumb.
They don't get it.
You're being "disruptive."
Right?
Now, Netflix had
truly been disruptive.
Right?
And I'm a big fan of
disruption, but it often
gets misused-- the
term-- and gets
pasted over things
that don't work.
Right?
And oh, well.
This is disruptive.
Well, then, of course, we're
supposed to support it.
Right?
And I was talking
at a CEO summit
last week-- a venture capital
summit here in San Francisco--
and disruption was the word of
the day, as you can imagine.
And I said look.
I like disruption, but only
when it's based on real customer
insights where we're solving
an unmet need, where we're
creating a solution
to a real pain point,
not for its own sake.
And it's taken on a bit
of a life of its own.
And this is in part due
to a professor of mine
at the Harvard Business School,
who in 1997, put out a book.
OK.
And the book knew-- so you guys
remember what 1997 was like.
I'm thinking maybe
some of you anyway.
And it was the early years
of the first dot-com boom.
Right?
Yahoo and Netscape
had gone public
in the previous two years.
Google wasn't even alive yet.
Wow.
But all the entrepreneurs
in Silicon Valley,
they had gold dollar
signs in their eyes.
Right?
They couldn't wait to build
and flip the next company,
and the customer was
really-- frankly,
let's be honest--
not in that equation.
OK.
And then my professor put
out a book they basically
said not only is
it not a problem
that you are ignoring
your customers,
it would be a problem
if you listened to them.
And you could hear the cheers
going up in Silicon Valley.
Yes.
Wow.
Not only do we not have
to feel bad about ignoring
our customers, we actually
can feel good about it.
It's intellectual
justification for doing
what we were already doing.
And the book, of course--
which you've heard of if not
read-- is "The
Innovator's Dilemma."
Now, there's a lot to like in
this book and especially a lot
to like in his later work,
but the thesis in the book
essentially is, if you
listen to your customers,
they'll tell you to
do the wrong thing
and they'll make you
vulnerable to some upstart that
comes along and disrupts you.
Right?
And interestingly, he amends
his thesis in his later work.
He says actually,
what I meant to say
is, if you focus on
their unmet needs,
then you can be disruptive.
But you can't really
ask them what they want.
Right?
And of course, and I've
believed that for 20 years.
Right?
That look, we have a
problem in the world
of customer experience.
Let's be honest.
Right?
If we think it's important to
include the customer in product
development, which I
do-- and I mentioned
I just joined the board of
Mind The Product, by the way.
It's a great community
of product leaders
from around the world and
bringing their first event
to the US-- they started
in Europe, actually--
in San Francisco this
June, if you're interested.
But if you believe it's
important to include
the customer when developing
and designing new products
and services, then
we have a problem,
which is we simply can't
ask-- what do you want?
Because people often don't know.
Not just customers.
We all have this
problem as human beings.
We often don't know we want.
Or we have a sense of it, but
we can't verbalize it very well.
Right?
So we have to find another way
to get at these unmet needs,
and we have to find a way
to sort of breakthrough
the blindness that companies
have about their customers.
That's the focus of
the end of my talk.
But before we get there, let me
finish the Netflix case study.
So what did Reed
Hastings do here?
Did he say yes, you're right.
I'm being disruptive.
The customers are stupid.
Damn the torpedoes?
No.
Actually, he did something
quite different and quite rare
for a CEO and,
frankly, a leader here
in Silicon Valley and something
that I think earned my respect
and should yours.
He said the following thing.
This was "arrogance
based on past success."
Wow.
That's quite an admission.
You know?
And look, in the course of human
affairs, if we're successful,
we become arrogant.
And a little bit of arrogance
is not a problem, I would argue.
I hope not because I am.
I need it to get up in the
morning, put a little spring
in my step, and I'm
guessing you do as well.
It's just when we get
extreme arrogance.
Well, remember
those plays we read
in high school, those
old Greek plays?
What was the word that
Greeks had for this?
AUDIENCE: Hubris.
PHIL TERRY: Hubris.
Hubris.
That's what we have
to watch out for,
and that's what happened here.
Reed Hastings and the team
at Netflix got some hubris.
Right?
And it blinded
them to the reality
of the ordinary unmet
needs of their customers.
OK.
So in addition to
disruption, we get excited
about the word "innovation."
Right?
And innovation is important.
Absolutely.
Obviously, Silicon
Valley is founded
on the notion of innovation.
Yet, sometimes, it becomes about
something more than innovating
around the simple unmet
needs of our customers.
And in fact, what
Reed Hastings said,
not only this-- that he was
arrogant-- but he realized
they had been chasing the
shiny object of innovation
and had lost track of
the ordinary unmet needs
of their customers.
He had lost track
of the housekeepers
we talked about earlier or
that taxi driver, you know,
or our sisters and brothers or,
for that matter, for all of us
in this room.
We are real, living,
breathing human beings.
And very often, the
things that we care about
are not the super exciting,
sexy, glamorous stuff
that's bandied
about in the press.
It's being able to actually do
the things we want to get done.
Companies frustrate us on the
most basic fundamental level.
Right?
Prices are too high, or
it's just too difficult
to get something done.
And of course, you
know this at Google
because you changed
everything here.
You remember the history.
Yahoo built Google.
Right?
So in the early days,
when Google came out,
the founders went around to
these different companies
and first tried to
sell the search engine,
and no one wanted to buy
it because Yahoo, Excite,
Altavista, Lycos,
they all believed
this is-- we're portals.
We don't want to help
people leave our website.
We want to stick them to
our website, and, in fact,
that's the word they used.
And as a customer, I've never
wanted to be "stuck" to anyone.
Thank you very much.
And of course, what was the
single most important and basic
thing that users of
the internet wanted
to do in 1999 and, by
the way, still today?
Search and find something,
and search sucked, frankly,
on those sites.
So Yahoo said, you know, OK.
Why don't you-- you'll
be our search engine.
And so when you
searched on Yahoo
and you got search
results, it actually
said "Powered by Google."
Yahoo built the Google brand
because Yahoo had misplaced
its focus on the
customer and instead was
focused on its
competitors and on this
inside the beltway
kind of attitude.
Right?
Well, the same thing
happened here at Netflix.
They lost sight of the basic
unmet needs of their customers,
and so what Reed
Hastings and the team did
is said let's get
back to the basics.
Forget about the shiny
object, and they relentlessly,
relentlessly, relentlessly
innovated around how
to-- what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Emily.
PHIL TERRY: How do we
make sure that when
Emily-- and I'm
making this up now.
When Emily puts her kids to
bed on a Friday night-- I don't
know if you have children--
and she has an hour
to watch something
on television,
she better not spend that
whole hour frustratingly
searching around
Netflix to try to find
something good to watch.
Right?
And they ended up doing a
project that had actually
started earlier in 2006, but
they put more emphasis on it,
and that is creating subgenres
to help you find things.
Right?
And so they actually had
a product development,
and Netflix put together
a-- do you know this story?
They put together
this big manual,
and they hired a bunch
of people to basically
watch TV shows and movies
and to tag those TV shows
and movies along a
number of dimensions.
Right?
Is this based in the
past, present, or future?
Is it a happy, sad, or
in-the-middle kind of ending?
Is it an action film that
has some interest to women
because it has an unusual
female protagonist?
Whatever the case may be.
And what's so interesting
is that Hollywood had never
done this.
Hollywood and the
American film industry
had been in business
for 100 years,
and they didn't know anything
about their own content.
Isn't that crazy?
They knew romantic comedy,
drama, sci-fi fantasy, action,
but holy-- that doesn't
tell you anything.
Does it?
So Netflix ended up creating
what they called "alt-genres."
I refer to them as "subgenres."
Whatever the case
may be, and you've
seen these because
you watch Netflix.
And now, you're going to see a
little bit about my wife and I
because these are the
subgenres that Netflix thinks
we think would be interesting.
And when the slide
comes up, you'll
see that it says things
like quirky crime television
dramas or dramas that dog lovers
home alone on a Friday night
might like.
Right?
And I only a little bit
joke about that last one.
Let me ask you a question.
Each customer is shown two
or three or four or five
of these subgenres or
alt-genres in their language,
but how many in total do
you think Netflix created?
AUDIENCE: Hundreds?
PHIL TERRY: Hundreds?
Emily's going for hundreds.
AUDIENCE: 2,000.
PHIL TERRY: 2,000?
You're going to just go for it.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyone else?
76,897.
AUDIENCE: Woah.
PHIL TERRY: Crazy.
Right?
Now, again, they didn't
show each customer
76,000 subgeneres.
That would have been terrible.
Right?
Now, if you watch
Netflix, you also
know that this actually didn't
completely solve the problem.
Right?
Because these were kind of fun.
And once in a while, it would
surface something that was
interesting, but
often, it didn't.
It's like stuff you'd maybe
seen already or really wasn't
that interesting to you.
Right?
But they kept it hammering
away on this question,
and they did this whole
crowdsource development
of their algorithm, a
new algorithm trying to--
and that was a very
interesting project.
Don't have time to
talk about it now.
They did this, but they
kept asking that question--
how do we make sure
Emily has something
to watch quickly and
easily that she likes?
Right?
And then what happened?
Well, they sort of
realized, holy moly.
There's not enough good content.
No matter what.
Our navigation or classification
scheme or algorithm,
Cinematch for recommending
TV shows and movies,
no matter how good
those things are,
there's a fundamental
problem, which
is there isn't the content
behind it to bring to Emily.
And then they did what?
AUDIENCE: They made their own.
PHIL TERRY: They made their own.
They made their own.
And so when the crisis
happened in 2011,
they had about 20 million
or so subscribers.
They lost close to a million.
Biggest negative, biggest
loss in their history
on a percentage basis, for sure.
But they started to
get back to the basics.
Right?
They realized they
had been arrogant.
They were chasing the
shiny object instead
of the basic needs
of their customers,
and then they created
the alt-genres
and then they decided to
get into original content.
So three and a half
years later-- only
three and a half years
later-- how many subscribers
do they have today?
Do you know?
They just came out
with their numbers.
AUDIENCE: 60 million?
PHIL TERRY: Yeah.
54.5 in the last quarter.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's quite a change.
Right?
Now, if we're here
in Silicon Valley
and we're talking about
product development,
we're talking about
customers, we're
talking about great
design, there's
always one name that comes up.
Right?
Well, you're talking about
customers, but what about--
AUDIENCE: Steve Jobs.
PHIL TERRY: Steve Jobs.
Thank you.
So the third chapter
of the book is
called "The
Misunderstood Mr. Jobs."
Right?
So the myth of Steve Jobs is
that he was a lone genius who
knew exactly what Emily wanted
before she herself knew,
without talking to
her or anything,
and delivered it right when
she was ready for it and boom,
hit the ball out of the park.
Right?
Well, the myth is partly true.
Well, certainly,
they hit the ball out
of the park with the iPhone.
You guys did a good
job with Android, too.
The numbers they
had last quarter
in the iPhone, unbelievable.
Right?
The problem they have
today is-- what's next?
But we're not going to
address that right now.
The myth that is not
true is it he was alone.
Obviously, a few
people worked at Apple.
But even more importantly--
and not well-known--
is that he got out
from behind his desk
and spent time with customers.
OK.
Now, he did not like
market research.
We all know this.
Surveys, focus
groups, I hope we all
know-- forget
those methodologies
when we're developing
new products.
That's a waste of time.
We can ask people
what they want.
But he did know-- he himself
had to get out and watch
as people used technology.
Right?
Now, to substantiate this claim,
we had a bit of a conundrum.
Like, we have some conviction
and direct experience
that we can't
relate in the book.
So what do we do?
And we couldn't find
anything on the internet
or in the public sphere
until we found finally
an article in "The New
York Times" at the end
of which a San Jose State
professor said, oh, yeah.
Steve Jobs got out and
observed customers.
Like, ah, finally.
A public thing we can point to.
It's true.
It just wasn't part of
the myth-making machine.
Now, what I do want
to do is I want
to show you a video
from 1997 of Steve Jobs.
Now, he doesn't say
he observed customers,
but you see his passion
for the customer experience
and it's one of the
clearest statements
that he made in
his whole career.
OK.
Now, 1997.
Do you remember what
was going on at Apple?
Anybody?
Almost out of cash.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL TERRY: Right?
So Jobs had been fired in
'85, left the board in '86.
Kind of wandered around in
the wilderness for awhile.
Started a company called "NeXT,"
turned out not to be next.
He did, though, buy this
little digital animation thing.
Right?
What was that?
AUDIENCE: Pixar.
PHIL TERRY: Ah, Pixar.
Pixar.
Fabulous.
Right?
That was good.
But by 1997, he was back
on the board at Apple.
And essentially, the board
said, well, you know,
we're going down anyway.
You might as well take over.
Like, what a great mandate.
And the first thing he does is
he shuts down a bunch of stuff.
Right?
And by the way, that pisses off
a lot of external developers
who had been working
on things like OpenDoc.
Some of you may remember
OpenDoc, which he shut down.
And all of the
sudden, the products
they were working on that had
been built to work with OpenDoc
were orphaned.
Right?
The video is kind of a
grainy, unauthorized video
from the Worldwide Developers
Conference in 1997 for Apple.
Has anyone been to the
WWDC for Apply, by the way?
I'm not-- you have?
Right.
Exactly.
But you have a sense of it?
Right?
What's it like?
What's your impression?
Light, sound, you know how
everyone's excited, you know,
blah, blah, blah.
Right?
Cult.
Well, that's not what
it was like in 1997.
It was the last 200 people who
were hoping it doesn't die,
but they're demoralized
and they're pissed off.
And when Steve Jobs says you've
got to start with the customer
experience, you'll
see in the audience,
people are like-- right?
[MUMBLING] They pan to the--
[MUMBLING] And then and then
you hear one person--
[SLOW CLAPPING]
[LAUGHTER]
This is not the cult
that we knew later.
This is the lowest
point in the company.
Right?
But it's that moment when he
chooses to make, what I think,
is the clearest statement about
his vision for how you think
about customers and technology.
So let's see if we
can watch this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --OpenDoc.
And when you're
finished with that,
perhaps you could tell
us what you personally
have been doing for
the last seven years.
-One of the hardest things, when
you're trying to effect change,
is that people
like this gentleman
are right in some areas.
I'm sure that there are some
things OpenDoc does-- probably
even more that I'm not
familiar with-- that nothing
else out there does.
And I'm sure of that
you can make some demos,
maybe a small commercial app
that demonstrates those things.
The hardest thing
is-- how does that
fit in to a cohesive
larger vision?
And one of the things
I've always found
is that you've got to start
with the customer experience
and work backwards
to the technology.
[APPLAUSE]
You can't start
with the technology
and try to figure out where
you're going to try to sell it.
And I've made this
mistake probably more
than anybody else in
this room and I've
got the scar tissue prove it
and I know that it's the case.
And as we have tried to come
up with a strategy and a vision
for Apple, it started with--
what incredible benefits
can we give to the customer?
Where can we take the customer?
Not starting with let's
sit down with the engineers
and figure out what
awesome technology we have,
and then how are we
going to market that.
And I think that's the
right path to take.
[END PLAYBACK]
PHIL TERRY: So I think
we all agree yes.
Start with the
customer experience,
not with the technology.
And what are the
amazing benefits?
Right?
And now, we get to the
conclusion of my talk
and the most important thing
that I learned in 15 years.
All right.
So much of the book,
we go through stories,
and I've shared some of
those with you today.
They're fairly straightforward.
You know, there wasn't
anything necessarily
revolutionary or
different about it.
I learned a lot from others.
Others learned from
me over the 15 years
that I led this customer
experience consultancy.
But there's one thing I learned
that was, unfortunately,
both the most powerful thing
and the least practiced.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHIL TERRY: Good?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHIL TERRY: OK.
OK.
And that's where
I want to conclude
with because I
want to see if this
will help you
think in a new way.
So if we agree that
we want to start
with the amazing
benefits, the problem
that we, of course,
have is-- how do you
figure those out, especially
if you can't go ask somebody?
What amazing benefits
do you want, Emily?
You're like, well, I--
[MUMBLING] You know--
[MUMBLING]
You know, we'll say something.
We'll give an answer, but
it doesn't necessarily
equate to what is, in fact,
really important to us.
Not because we don't want to
be honest, but because we,
as human beings,
often don't know.
So what do we do?
Well, what we learned and
what I learned is, one,
get out from behind your
desk and observe customers.
So yes.
Is data important?
I love data.
I love big data.
I love small data.
I love medium data.
[CHUCKLES]
I love data of all
sizes and kinds.
Data tells you what, but it
often doesn't tell you why.
Right?
And you need some observations
of real living human beings,
like the housekeepers
that we were talking
about earlier, the taxi driver,
or your mother, or whatever.
Right?
People that we're
designing this product for.
We need a few of real
life human beings,
and we need it for two reasons.
One, because it gives us more
of the why and fills out what
we are looking at in
the data, but we need it
for a second reason.
OK.
And this is not well-understood.
When we work inside companies,
within about six months
of working for a
company, we start
to see the world from the
company's point of view.
We start to absorb the
values and perspective
of the companies that
we're working with.
This is very important
and very powerful,
but there's a weakness
embedded in it,
which is that we lose the
capacity to understand
our business from the
customer's point of view,
from their perspective, to
have empathy for what it's
like for someone who
doesn't have our knowledge
and our perspective to use
our products and services.
It happens no matter who
you are and no matter
which company you're in.
In fact, you start to develop
a kind of confirmation bias.
Right?
So you guys are
familiar with this term,
and you know the whole field
of behavioral economics.
I talk a lot about it
in my book because it
had a big impact on
me, and it really
helped me understand what
I'm talking about right now.
So in 1999-- well, in 1998,
we had worked for Travelocity
and created the first
Fast Fare Finder.
Big hit.
Then the head of
Product Development,
a guy named Chuck Geiger, move
from Travelocity to Gateway.
And he called us and said would
you come help us out here?
We're not doing as well
with our e-commerce,
and we want to be
more like Dell.
OK.
Gateway at the time had a
great case of Dell envy.
Envy is like arrogance.
It blinds you.
Right?
So to Chuck, I said, if we
find out from the data analysis
and spending some time
with your customers
that you need to be more like
Dell, we'll certainly say that.
But if we find something else
out, we'll tell you that, too.
We're not going to tell you what
you want to hear, as you know.
He said great.
Fine.
And then I had this brainstorm.
It was lucky.
I can't tell you
that it was something
that I had thought about
for years and understood.
I just-- I don't know.
I ate something good
for breakfast that day.
I said to Chuck--
would you please
invite some of the other
leaders from Gateway
to come out with us to observe
Gateway potential customers
and current customers
researching and shopping
for a computer online?
And he said OK.
Thank God.
Because it ended up being the
most important thing that I
learned.
So we brought
people-- let's say,
Emily here who was
shopping for a computer,
thinking about buying
a Gateway, and was
thinking about buying it online.
OK.
You had to, of course,
understand, in 1999,
many people weren't
necessarily buying online.
And we brought them
in, and we said, Emily,
you're in the market
to buy a computer.
We understand.
Great.
And you're thinking OK.
Cool.
Would you just
shop and research?
We're not going to say much.
Don't mind us.
Just think out loud.
It's not a usability test.
We're not going to task you.
It's not a focus group.
We're not interested
in your opinions.
We're going to watch.
So Emily tools around.
And sad for Emily--
and by the way,
I say this in all of my talks.
Google wasn't up yet.
OK.
So she's struggling with bad
search results that Altavista
and Lycos and Excite
and Yahoo or whatever--
and she finally
makes it to Gateway,
and the Gateway
homepages a trainwreck.
Right?
And she gets
completely frustrated.
Now, with the leaders
behind the glass
she types in-- on her own,
without any prompting from us--
Dell.com, and you can imagine
what they-- [MUMBLING]
And she's not our customer.
[CHUCKLES]
I said all right.
She struggles over at Dell.
We bring her back to Gateway.
We say let's just go back
there, and we get her
into the process.
Now, we learned some important
things-- at that moment,
important to Gateway.
The most important
thing we learned
is it the paradigm
that gateway and Dell
had created in the 1980s.
The way that they sold
computers, which was you
tell us what you want.
You configure it.
We'll build it and send it to
you was not working anymore
for the Emilys of the world.
Emily didn't want to
configure her computer.
She didn't know what RAM was.
She just wanted the whole thing.
She doesn't know how to get it,
but she was very frustrated.
And here's the remarkable thing.
By the end of two days-- just
two days-- of watching Emily
and Emily 1, 2, 3,
4, up to Emily 16
and we saw the similar pattern
without tasking or setting
the context, by the
end of those two days,
not only had we learned
something important that helped
foot and explain the data
that we had analyzed,
but more importantly than
that, the leaders of Gateway
themselves had
changed their minds.
They had actually gone
through their own confirmation
bias, which is notoriously
difficult to change,
and come out on the other side.
They had developed some
empathy and compassion
and understanding for Emily's
perspective on Gateway
and how to buy a
computer, not their own.
And that just blew my mind.
Like holy moly.
Confirmation bias.
First of all, you don't
know when you have it.
You don't know when
it's operating.
OK.
If you read all the way to the
end of Daniel Kahneman's book,
"Thinking, Fast and Slow"--
has anyone attempted that
by the way?
I know.
It's actually a little hard
to read, but it's worth it.
So he's the co-founder
of behavioral economics,
wins the Nobel Prize,
blah, blah, blah.
40 years of research
proving that we
don't know what we're
doing most of the time.
And at the end of the book, he
says, despite all of this-- me
being a co-founder, that
is, winning the Nobel Prize,
discovering confirmation bias
recently or co-discovering
or doing research around it,
whatever the case may be-- I
myself, Daniel Kahneman,
have no idea when
I'm doing all of these things.
What?
The world expert, the one
who co-founded the field?
He himself has no idea?
What are we supposed
to do about all this?
So we have the knowledge,
but the knowledge
doesn't change our behavior.
OK.
Well, it helped clarify, for
me-- he then says this, though.
He says, if you're
in a social context,
if you see and connect
with other people,
it starts to expose for
you some of these biases
in yourself and in others.
I though, oh.
That's what we learned in 1999.
And that's why every
project after that-- the 400
projects we did, whether we
were working with Facebook,
helping them figure out-- are
non-college students interested
in Facebook?
Right?
The early days of Facebook.
Now, they're trying
to figure out
if college students
are interested.
Hey, you've got
1.3 billion users.
So what the hell.
Right?
Whether it's that or working
with a company like American
Express or whatever the
case may be, I set a rule.
Anyone who has a say on
this product or service--
and by the way, veto power
over what the team comes up
with in terms of a new product,
like service or experience--
has to come out and directly
observe some of this research
themselves.
It's the only way that we
will shift their perspective.
It doesn't matter how
good our data analysis
is if they already have
a sacred assumption
about the way they're working.
They won't see the
full implications.
We need this, and it's
such a simple thing.
Notice I'm not trying to
create a complicated framework
with a cool piece of
jargon around it and maybe
some copyright, and you have to
license this from me to do it.
No.
I'm simply saying get
out from behind your desk
and make a habit of it.
And obviously, you
can't do it all the time
and different people
have different roles,
but don't let it be a group over
here that does it and reports
back to you and you
yourself have never done it.
Steve Jobs did it.
Sam Walton did it.
I have a whole case study
in the book about Walmart
that I think you'll find
very, very interesting
and a colossal
mistake they later
made because they got
more focused on themselves
and their envy of that
French retailer, Target,
than on their
ordinary customers.
And they lost context
and the ability to see,
and they didn't
go into the stores
as much as they once did.
Warren Buffett, by
the way, does this.
Little known fact.
Like, Warren Buffett?
He's a customer experience
leader, a pioneer?
What?
That guy in Omaha?
Yes, actually.
That guy.
When he made an all-important
investment in American Express
in the early '60s, he actually
went out and watched people
using their American
Express cards.
You want to know the
only thing he did?
He did a-- you know,
the guy's a wizard.
He did all kinds of analysis,
but he did that, too.
OK.
Some of the best
companies do this,
and it's the simple
message that I have.
At the end of the day, we'll
end with where we started.
We're dealing with real people,
really human beings, employees,
customers, real
living human beings.
And it turns out we human beings
are, despite what we think,
more similar to
each other then we
are different in a
vast variety of ways.
The only way we
can remember what
it's like to be a
customer of our company
is to get out and spend
some time with them.
Not in a focus group
where we're giving them
some artificial construct
or a usability test
and there's value for those,
but direct observations
of people searching
or people using email.
Right?
And I know you do this, and
you do this to some extent.
But all of you need
to do this, and you
need to make a
regular habit of it.
And what I find is that
companies, even those that
know it, forget it
sometimes, and that,
in fact, is the most
important thing that I learned
and the simplest, simplest
recommendation I have for you.
So thank you so much
for having me here.
It was really a pleasure.
And why don't we conclude?
And if there are any
comments or questions,
we can end with that.
AUDIENCE: You showed
the Steve Jobs video.
PHIL TERRY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And you just have said
that the customer is the focus,
and we start with the customer
and go back to the technology.
PHIL TERRY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But as
an engineer, if I
have this awesome,
cool technology which
is awesome for me.
But it's just a technology.
It's not a product yet.
PHIL TERRY: That's all right.
AUDIENCE: So like, what
is your advice for me
to go and find the right
customers for such a scenario?
PHIL TERRY: Well,
you know, it's great.
And obviously, engineers are
the backbone of Silicon Valley.
Right?
But my message to you is
get out and spend some time
with your end-users.
Right?
And there's a lot of reasons.
There's time, people are busy.
There's a lot of things
that we could talk about.
It's awkward.
Frankly, one of the--
it's emotionally hard
to spend time with customers.
It really-- because they
trample all over the things
you care about
without knowing it.
Right?
And then, you know, this thing
you thought was so important,
they don't give a damn about.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHIL TERRY: But I
would say you do
some unstructured observations--
not even about the technology
necessarily that
you're working on,
although maybe in
that sphere-- just
to try to understand-- where are
some pain points and obstacles?
And let that guide.
You have great--
I'm going to assume.
We don't know each
other, but I'm
going-- you know, if you're
an engineer here at Google,
you've got some
great skill, talent,
maybe you have some real
insights about some technology.
That's really valuable.
What you may not
have as much of it
is a real empathetic
understanding of your customer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHIL TERRY: Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: But the
way you suggest--
So if I start looking
at the customers,
what problems they're
experiencing, and try
to draw back to the
technology, then
I might find the technology I
started with wouldn't, like,
fit that particular case.
PHIL TERRY: That's right.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: Right?
PHIL TERRY: Because
maybe there's
this ancillary technology
or this quarter-inch turn
you can make that-- wow.
I didn't even think
about that because you
can't because you're
inside the company.
It's by nature you cannot
see the customer the way
the customers see you
and what their needs are.
No matter how smart you are.
One of the bottom lines of my
book-- knowledge is not enough.
It's frustrating,
especially for those of us
who have built
our careers on it.
It's important, but
it's not enough.
We also need empathy.
We need the heart and the head.
AUDIENCE: Around, like,
in larger companies, how
do you build kind of the
excitement about customer
experience and really
staying customer-focused.
I know like--
PHIL TERRY: Yeah.
There's a lot of complexity.
AUDIENCE: YEah.
PHIL TERRY: Right?
Absolutely.
And I don't want to pretend
that's not true, but you know,
what I always say-- I was a
community organizer before I
got into business.
Maybe you picked that up a
little bit in sort of how I am.
Right?
I really do care about people,
and I care about communities.
And what you learn, as
a community organizer,
if you want to change
things in the world,
is that it's brick by brick.
It's slow.
And many people complain
to me, oh, you know,
I can't get the culture here to
change, and my answer to them
is you've got the
wrong time horizon.
OK.
If you're hoping to have
an impact on the culture
and the degree of momentum,
excitement, et cetera,
that takes time.
It doesn't happen overnight.
Most people quit before
it really happens.
So we all know a little bit
about the Civil Rights Movement
and we know about Martin
Luther King's speech in 1963,
but do you know how many
decades people were working
to create the possibility
for the Civil Rights Movement
to emerge?
When was the NAACP founded?
Does anyone else?
If you had to guess?
AUDIENCE: 1970s?
PHIL TERRY: You're
in the neighborhood.
It was just the beginning
of the 20th century.
Right?
And of course, there were
abolitionists and others.
I mean, this is--
and in fact, if you
want to really understand
the time horizon,
we're just now, in
the West, beginning
to have a society where
women are more equal.
Right?
They were always
equal fundamentally,
but not treated as such.
2,500 years ago, Plato,
in "The Republic,"
calls for the complete
equality of women
in every aspect of life--
military, political, business.
The whole kit and caboodle.
Then it took us 2,500
years to get to the point
where we're starting
to act on that.
These are long-time horizons.
Now, I'm not suggesting it's
going to take 2,500 years.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's going to be more than a
week and then more than a month
and, more likely,
more than a year.
Right?
But you can start
small, start somewhere.
Where is there an opening?
Where is there an
engineer who wants
to get out a little
bit from the box
and do something a
little different?
Work with that person.
See if you can develop
some success around that,
and then keep going.
And get in touch with me if you
ever want some sounding board
advice or what have you.
AUDIENCE: Oh, thank you.
PHIL TERRY: Yeah.
Thank you.
Cool.
I know there are
people on Hangout,
and I don't know if they're
able to ask questions or--
MALE SPEAKER: Not really, no.
But they'll follow up later.
PHIL TERRY: They'll follow up.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
PHIL TERRY: My email address is
pterry@collaborativegain.com.
And if that's too long,
it's pterry@gmail.com.
[LAUGHTER]
By the way, I'll tell you
that-- since I'm at Google,
I'll just end with this.
So I was one of the
earliest Gmail users
because of Marissa and
Bradley and others here,
and I'm so happy to
get that email address.
Right?
Every single day-- I'm
not talking about spam.
Every single day, I
get email from people
all over the world who think I'm
someone else because my email
address is so simple.
I'm Pam Terry, Patricia
Terry in England,
and all over the world.
I get bank account sign-ups.
People sign-- and then, "Here's
your bank"-- I'm like, "Oh,
shit."
You know, and I'm
like calling the bank.
This is not me, and you
don't want this information.
[CHUCKLES]
I have actually a folder
in my Gmail account
called "Other Phils" where
I have years of these.
I might actually
write a book about--
MALE SPEAKER:
[INAUDIBLE] take it away.
PHIL TERRY: What's that?
MALE SPEAKER: We can take
it away, if that's a--
PHIL TERRY: Oh, no.
But I love my email address.
[LAUGHTER]
I love my email address.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
PHIL TERRY: My
only disappointment
is I didn't do phil@gmail,
although, I think,
actually that was
taken at that point.
But anyway, so
thank you so much.
Please take a look at the book.
Let me know what you
think, and stay in touch.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
PHIL TERRY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]